[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
the week 8 update has dropped early and
therefore i'm back again with your
fortnite update
if you're new around these parts i'm not
a regular then no
this is the series where we look for map
changes and secrets in the world of
fortnite
if you'd like to support these
shenanigans please think about using
code adamaru in the store
and above all else please click
subscribe it's totally free and
percent of you watching right now
haven't clicked it yet
anyway fortnite map changes chapter two
season three week
eight early let's do this
[Music]
i began my hunt by first visiting graham
the gnome master
this time i decided to take him with me
by quickly attaching him to a pickaxe
graham has evolved and will be with us
from here on out
just below his shack the water levels
have dropped once again
and look what is now fully uncovered the
astronaut pod
is now accessible last week we all
noticed this bad boy underwater with a
thruster embedded in the rock face
nearby
and this week things became insanely
good for anyone who wants a bit of law
or a bit of change in fortnite
by finding three parts for the ship we
can trigger the next evolution in
fortnite br
and the return of something great the
thruster like we said is embedded in the
mounting face
but by listening out to the sound we can
find two other things
the battery which is near this rock
hidden under the water
next swim over to the shore and hiding
behind another rock
is the heat shield take all these three
parts back to the ship
and enjoy this moment
the ship has once again returned to
outer space using a rift
but look what was left behind smaller
rifts are back in fortnite
think of all the myths we can try now
you're thinking what i'm thinking
marauders in a rift it's going to be
epic that's going to be my next video
so while we wait for cars to be added
there's fun to be had here
from a story sense this small act from
an intergalactic vessel giving us tech
inadvertently
is massive i think one day we will hunt
down singularity in her mech
do you remember when she flew away after
the greatest boss battle in video game
history i want to give her a high five
no in fact i want to give her a high 10.
oh she's only got one arm okay one high
five is cool girl
also the rift is so fun to use and
brings back those memories from chapter
one
good times the question remains though
will porter riffs return to the core
game
we've seen that they work completely
fine in the ltms so maybe
they're back soon
[Music]
next the biggest change of the week and
no it's not atlantis we'll get to that
soon enough
it's truckasaurus he has finally reached
land after being trapped underwater for
months
he crawled onto the shore just above the
docks our hero is
one step closer to battling the
splashback spartan
who waits ready for battle i'm sure
you've noticed
that truckasaurus has no head this
doesn't look to be deliberate though
instead the removal of all vehicles in
the game while epic makes them function
correctly
has probably caused this but here's a
cool thing to note
this confirms truckasaurus head will be
a drivable vehicle in fortnite
he's come a long way this old timer the
transformer rig of optimus prime
is one step closer every update poll
time
well no poll because youtube removed
them but here's the big question of the
day
who will win in the battle between
truckasaurus and the splashback spartan
my money is on trackosaurus he's been
beat up and battered
but he knows how to survive but i
suppose the splashback spartan has taken
a lot of
sugar too i should move on
[Music]
so atlantis is finally here and it's
named coral castle in game
damn it looks good the home of the dc
superfish dude
arthur aka aquaman the poi features many
brand new assets
and is surrounded by a pretty cool
waterfall i have another question
what the heck are these things am i
missing something or is that a
defective fish in a bowl hmm the layout
around here makes for an awesome sight
and have you checked out the statues and
sculptures yet
there's detail here to be found in the
last battle pass we were introduced to
deadpool's yacht which also had crazy
amounts of detail going on
i like what you're doing epic more of
this please around this area we can
finally see the crashed ego plane from
the first day of chapter two
the original settlers the plane has seen
better days with parts falling deeper
into the ocean
but it's here and the importance of that
logo is more intriguing than ever the
key to the bunker
one day probably in 2023 we will get
in that bunker also note the pirate
radio ship is still here
this is interesting as many other boats
have been removed
remember the galleon i called it a
pirate ship for weeks we watched it make
more twists and turns than a cheap
garden
hose it looked to be crashing into the
dam at one point
and then it looked to be crashing into
the tortilla but in the end
it simply vanished that can't be right
ripped the dream also has the dance boat
gone you know the one with the dance
floor on it
i can't seem to find it help me out in
the past we've lost the piranha island
we've lost the no sweat insurance
storage building
but the pirate radio ship remains why
is that from the outside we can see this
is a direct link to midas the man who
showed us the real world in the last
fortnight event
and the man we're not sure if he's alive
or eliminated forever
his poster stands proud and inside is
the original logo from the agency
and also note that this is a pirate
radio station with all the radio gear
but it's literally a ship on water
so play on the words pirate radio you
get it funny not funny
shut up adam i'll move on you visited
swetie sands recently
well now the tides have turned we can
see the golden sands have come back
and this spot is looking more og than
ever if you remember in season one
there was a wooden building we started
to watch here but
nothing happened for so long we forgot
it was there
well now finally after this update that
building
has become this another gas station here
for the vehicles
whenever they arrive by the way call of
duty's new season drops this week do you
think epic will release vehicles at the
same time and day maybe
to drive attention back to fortnite that
would explain why they've updated the
map on a saturday
instead of a tuesday hmm what will
happen on tuesday
find out next time another strange
update in 20 sans is the addition
of a basketball court i know it's not a
big deal right
well you should take more time to really
look at this
because things are not as they seem it's
a tiny update
but one of the hoops is a tiny bit
higher than the other one
it's only a few inches so i forgive you
if you don't see it right away
okay it's totally messed up in the best
way possible
check out the sick free throws nothing
but net
i feel we need a pointless competition
right now anyone who can hit a trick
shot that blows my mind
will be featured in the next map update
video last time we did this it was
bottle flips for hot watch
in chapter one those were good memories
let's call this
meatball madness use twitter to dm me a
link to your youtube video
if you want to take part here's a funky
update which i have no
idea what it represents up by steamy
stacks there is a cove
which originally had an rv camper well
now the water levels have plummeted
this thing is here instead it makes no
sense at
all right now a simple shack with a
basic fishing hole
nothing more could it be challenge
related maybe
or will this expand into something new
what am i missing something feels
wrong here i feel like i'm missing
something help a brother out
it looks like the water level is back
down to what we saw last season
rivers are back to normal and the sea
level looks correct
to me the tortilla has slightly shifted
and a gas station has been added ready
for the cars
and this lowering has brought back many
old points of interest
including slurpy swamps and weeping
woods
but both are a complete mess the water
has left a lasting effect here and you'd
expect this to be tidied up over the
last few weeks of the season but there
is something you should see with your
own two eyes
the legacy of graham's army remember
last season when the misfit bears
escaped the christmas trucks and began
to take over the map
they set up this hidden bunker and
captured this guy
do i still have to say his name whenever
we mention him
okay i'll say his name gandalf keemstar
jerome the genome
but by the end of the season a treaty
was signed and that story ended
in the first week of season three well
right now that narrative has been frozen
in time
letting us take graham to see his
brother in captivity
what a touching moment and if you
figured out i was going to do this with
graham at the start of the video
extra points to you gg i'm impressed and
finally the lowered water brought back
the mess of tubes and pipes at the south
part of the map
i assumed this meant that the pipe man
tony stank
would return too i searched the shore
but sadly
i cannot find our iron man anywhere at
all
please help me find this washed up hero
at one point he looked like he was going
to that pipe mess to build something
but he never got there the flood took
him out
so what did i miss from the week 8
update and why do you think they brought
it forward three days
could cars be arriving on tuesday hmm i
hope so
on screen now are the legends who used
code adamaru last week
i wasn't expecting an update video today
so my list is not complete my apologies
i will get back to you soon
to be shouted out please use code
adamara in the store and send a before
and after pic to my twitter
as my dms are open i'm adam from
playstation grenade and it's been a
pleasure
right now i'm going to throw a marauder
into a rift happy days
bye